c'est un trésor de 13 millions d'euros
que doit trouver la gloire à sion de
saint quentin en yvelines
l' avantage fiscal dont bénéficie la
collectivité pour sa participation au
système de péréquation sera remise en
cause dès l'an prochain pour trouver de
l'argent sans augmenter les impôts ou
réduire les services la majorité
réfléchit donc à évoluer et pourrait
rejoindre le club très fermé des
communautés urbaines
ça nous donnerait une bouffée d'air de
l'ordre de 8 à 9 millions d'euros par an
pour pouvoir se poser et prendre le
temps peut-être pour faire d'autres
réformes sur le long terme pour changer
de statut saint-quentin-en-yvelines
devra nouveau s'élargir pour atteindre
le seuil de 250 mille habitants une
option que l'opposition de gauche ne
rejette pas même si pour elle un large
débat territoriale doit être rapidement
mise en place
la base c'est une discussion d'abord
entre nous par rapport aux différentes
compétences qu'on souhaite et aux
différentes
une coopération qu'on souhaite entre nos
communes et après on verra
vers qui on se tourne cette discussion
s'est inscrit dans le vote plus large du
budget 550 millions d'euros approuvée
par les élus avec 46 voix pour et 25
abstentions un budget qualifié de
transition et d'attentes par la majorité
les délibérations pour le transfert de
compétences patine depuis plusieurs mois
on est une seule intercours bien avant
tours on est douze maires et avant de
penser peut-être à l'intercommunalité
chaque maire défend un peu sa propre
ville on n'a pas trouvé encore le rythme
qu'il faut et c'est vrai que sans ce
rythme là on a du mal à se projeter dans
l'avenir
les élus ont également voté le maintien
des impôts locaux à leur taux actuel le
prochain conseil d'agglomération est
prévue le 29 mai prochain l'évolution de
l'intercommunalité devrait une nouvelle
fois rythmé les débats